well media critics are hammering the
mainstream media for its coverage of
those recently released emails from dr
anthony fauci
a bunch of outlets are hailing dr
fauci's frank honesty
but critics question how the media has
framed all of this the washington post
tweeting quote anthony fauci's pandemic
emails from march and april 2020
obtained through the freedom of
information act
offer a peek into his world during the
frantic early days
of the coronavirus crisis and they do
indeed joe concha is a fox news
contributor also a media columnist for
the hill he is here to break it all down
for us
um joe i think the first question that
needs to be asked here
um about these this trove of emails is
which portrait of dr fauci do they paint
is he this reluctant media hero thrust
into the spotlight by former president
trump
or is he a very savvy political operator
who sort of took the reins and managed
washington's response to the pandemic
what i'm seeing mostly jillian
incredibly
is the continued lionization of dr
anthony thaucy because let's think about
what these emails reveal right it shows
that fauci was cognizant of a possible
lag lead
it also shows that dr fauci arguing that
retail mass may not be very effective
in protecting people from coven but most
importantly it gives two
examples of fouchy sharing documents as
they relate
to gain of function contradicting his
testimony
to senator rand paul not too long ago
and remember from a media perspective
facebook censored any post that
suggested that covet was man-made that
it happened in a lab
many in media last year portrayed
anybody who suggested this
such as senator tom cotton or donald
trump as a
conspiracy theorist and was it so
outlandish that this came from a lab
when you look at the president
2004 sars escaped from a chinese lab
years before that anthrax escaped from
a soviet lab so the president was there
and you have to wonder was this
reporting based on feelings and
favoritism or was it based on facts
the former jillian well here's another
key question i think
journalists and pundits alike have to
ask themselves
how much wiggle room do you give dr
fauci or any public health official
when you enter a situation like this
that is unprecedented that is a global
crisis people don't have answers they
are
scrambling do you make some allowances
for getting things wrong for maybe being
wishy-washy or even going back and forth
on things
you know what i'm you know what i'm
saying joe like how much room do you
give him here
or none at all of course well look if
there was some contrition on dr fauci's
part that would be one thing this is
somebody
who wants to release a book in november
that book by the way has been scrubbed
by amazon and barnesandnoble.com it
appears but this really sticks out to me
and it hit me
before i came on the air and you had dr
fauci checking in with cnn anchor chris
cuomo on a nightly basis while this
pandemic
was raging let me give you the quote
from cuomo to fouchy in april of 2020
quote
i have spoken to you almost without
exception every day and you have been
calling me out of personal concern to
make sure i'm okay
11 o'clock at night later waiting for my
show to end saturday
sunday morning why is dr fauci during a
raging pandemic
calling a democratic activist who plays
an anchor on tv
on a nightly basis when that anchor was
still healthy enough to do his program
if that was his priority i give him zero
wiggle room when it comes to that
because it shows that dr fauci
was seeing things through a political
prison and two-thirds of americans agree
with me on that according to a recent
wrath wasn't paul jillian
uh joe thanks for always calling it like
you see it i will say it would be nice
to see public health officials and
politicians
stop with the multi-million dollar book
writing while the pandemic
is still raging on and killing thousands
of americans every single week all right
joe concha thanks so much we appreciate
it
amen jillian